This is how you succeed in contradicting thePflegegradeinstufung.
In Germany,
that almost 20 percent of all nursing grade applications are rejected
and many others are classified differently,
than the people in need of care or their relatives expect,
or
would have wished.
This is very,
of course.
What you can do about it is,
you can file an appeal.
For this to be successful,
you need to consider 3 things:
1.
You must meet the deadline.
Because within 4 weeks
or after one month after service of the notice
you must have filed an objection.
At first,
this can be formless.
2.
But you must also justify your objection afterwards.
You can only do that,
if you know the nursing report.
So you demand submission with objection
Insight into the nursing report.
Based on the expert opinion
you can then justify your own contradiction.
3.
Most of the time it is hard for you as a caring relative,
to read the expert opinion correctly.
So you should get support in any case
from your doctor or the family doctor of the person in need of care,
From professional caregivers or nursing counseling.
With them you then work through the expert opinion
and create based on it
a well-founded contradiction.
You then send the whole thing back to the checkout.
My tip on this:
What you should do in any case is keep a care diary.
That is,
you write down,
when you or someone else
helped your relative in need of care.
Ultimately,
the care level is evaluated above it,
how great the need for help is in everyday life.
And that's exactly what you can prove with your care diary.
You can hold on like this,
Who supported,
when and to what extent.
This also helps with the filing of the opposition.
And best of all:
Through the link in my profile you will find a template directly,
to file the simple objection.